the Iranian government has imposed
sanctions on German politicians and
institutions including DW's Farsi
service DW's director General Peter
Limburg has strongly criticized the move
and urged EU leaders to increase the
pressure on the regime in Tehran
we highly condemn the move of the
Iranian regime it is totally
unacceptable
how how will these sanctions affect the
people on this list are they and their
families in any danger
I think yes it is much more dangerous if
you are on such a list we we cannot see
into the hearts and minds of the Iranian
government but the danger is now bigger
than before for the people who might not
travel again to Iran because they are on
the list who still were able to travel
and especially for their family members
who are in Iran and we have seen that
the Iranian government has harassed the
people of our staff and they also arrest
the members of their family so I think
the danger is bigger now than before
how will these sanctions affect dwu's
reporting in Iran
I think we will continue to do what we
did and the situation hasn't changed
dramatically concerning our reporting we
see it as our task to bring unbiased and
correct information to our users in Iran
in our father department and we will
continue to do so
and what is DW doing to fight these
sanctions
well first of all I think we have to
condemn them and we have to name what it
is the Iranian government is sponsoring
Terror within its own country but also
abroad and I urge German and European
politicians to put more pressure on Iran
to really highlight this topic because
it has been a scandal in the past how
Iran is treating International media and
it is a scandal now